game of thrones season 6 episode 6 is
out let's have a look beyond the wall
mira desperately tries to outrun the
white striking brown along behind her
you've got to admire a loyalty instead
of dumping bran and saving herself she
continues to risk her life to protect
him she must really believe what the
raven claims
that bran is important for the war to
come against the white walkers
anyway while mira does all the work bran
is tripping balls having visions of the
future and past he sees winter and
weirwoods and ravens which are
associated with green sight
the magic of his visions he sees
daenerys and her dragons including one
shot of a dragon flying over king's
landing
he sees whites and white walkers and the
night king and the night king's creation
by the children of the forest
he sees that one time a white walker
took a baby to the far north and the
night king seemed to convert it into a
walker
he sees the fall that crippled him and
the deaths of his parents and his
brother he sees what's inside the tower
of joy though we'll have to wait till
episode 10 to see
more and he sees aerys targaryen the
father of daenerys and viserys and
rhaegar
heiress ruled as the king of westeros
before robert but he was mad and cruel
he loved to burn people alive in fact
one of the people he burned was
rickard stark the father of ned stark
who we saw last episode
rickard's death was one of the events
that led houses aaron stark and tully to
rally behind robert baratheon and rebel
against
aerys the climax of this war was when
robert baratheon killed aerys
heir prince rhaegar at the battle of the
trident but heiress himself didn't die
until the latest sack of king's landing
when tywin lannister marched on the
capital
during this battle aerys was killed by
his own kingsguard
a young jaime lannister he murdered the
king he was sworn to protect then he sat
on the iron throne waiting to see who
would come to claim the kingdom
we learn in season 3 in that amazing
bath scene that the reason why jaime
killed heiress is that aerys had
secretly placed caches of wildfire all
over king's landing
wildfire is that explosive green stuff
tyrion used to blow up stannis fleet
so jaime learned that heiress was
planning to burn down
king's landing and he saved the city by
killing aerys but the thing is
those caches of wildfire are still down
there a powder kick right under the
capital just waiting for a spark
and in bran's vision he foresees them
exploding
some readers believe that cersei will
try to light the wildfire and that jaime
will have to kill her to stop her
fulfilling the valonqar prophecy but
this shot of what's probably dany's
dragon drogon over the cities suggests
that it might be dragon fire that sets
off the wildfire
however it happens by the time dany
takes the capital there might not be
much of a city left to rule
after all these visions bran unplugs
from the matrix and finds that the
whites are right behind him it looks
like they're gonna die but then they're
saved by a strange figure wearing black
down in the reach sam and gilly head for
horn hill sam's family home and this is
amazing for gilly
all she's ever known before is craster's
cape and castle black such
bleak cold places so the south is a
whole new world for her
sam is very nervous he's bringing his
girlfriend home to meet his parents and
while his mother and sister are lovely
his father is an abusive [ __ ] who
threatened to kill him for not being
manly enough
also he has to lie about gilly's son and
say it's his when it's actually
craster's and he has to hide the fact
that gilly is a wildling so this
homecoming is a stressful one for sam
in king's landing tommen talks with a
high sparrow and tormund is surprisingly
cool with the idea of his wife margery
being paraded naked through this city
the sparrow lets tommen see margery and
marge appears to have given
in to the high sparrow's brainwashing
she says she once lied to make herself
seem sweet and kind but now she's found
her faith
she says the gods have a plan for us all
has marge really suddenly become
a good little christian in episode 4 she
seemed not at all convinced by the
sparrow
but she did see her beloved brother
laura suffering so maybe margery
realized that she needed a change in
strategy
maybe she figures if she plays along
with the sparrows she could get in a
position to strike
back at horn hill gilly and sam have an
awkward dinner with sam's family
sam mentions gilly as a good hunter and
randall disapproves he's got strong
ideas about what women should and
shouldn't do in the books he meets
brienne and calls her a freak of nature
and a curse upon her father for wanting
to fight and be a knight
randall finds out gilly is a wildling so
he calls her a savage and a wildling
[ __ ]
he goes on a rant about how sam's a
piece of [ __ ] for not being a big tough
warrior and while he allows gilly and
her baby to stay at horn hill he kicks
him out of his home
so sam says farewell to gilly but then
impulsively changes his mind and decides
to bring gilly and young sam with him
and on his way out he takes heartsbane
randall's priceless valyrian steel
greatsword which seems like a really bad
idea
heartspain is the freudian pride of
randall's house there is no doubt
randall will come after it and what's
ham even planning to do with it
valyrian steel can apparently kill white
walkers but sam's not going back to the
wall until he studied at the citadel for
a while
and what about gilly it's very romantic
to take her with him but she was offered
a place at horn hill the safest place
she's likely to get to stay
is it really fair on her or her infant
child to take her away from that
sam better have a plan here over in
braavos aya sees that play again with
their version of the purple wedding with
the pie the wine when joffrey dies and
tywin's death by tyrion
arya enjoys seeing joffrey die she's
wanted to kill him for a long time but
cersei played by lady crane gives a
speech about her grief at her son's
death
and arya seems moved maybe she wonders
if killing really is the right thing to
do
she does poison lady crane's rum anyway
but then she bumps into her on the way
out and they chat and they connect over
their shared experience in acting
crane asks her name and aya says mercy
so later
mercy shows mercy running back and
stopping crane from drinking the poison
at the last minute so here aya makes her
choice
she refuses to give up her sense of
what's right she refuses to give up who
she is
she goes and she gets needle from its
hiding place drawing it from stone like
excalibur and this represents her
re-embracing her connection to her
family
in the books it says needle is rob and
bran and rickon her mother her father
even
sansa needle is jon snow's smile she is
returning to her identity as arya stark
which means she's breaking from the
faceless men
the waif sees all this and gets
permission from jaqen to kill arya
it's interesting that the waif so
obviously wants to kill arya just look
at that bloody smirk when as a faceless
man she's not meant to care who she
kills she's meant to have no desires or
personality
she's meant to be no one so is the waif
breaking her own rules
maybe arya will somehow exploit the
waif's humanity to defeat her
because she's going to need some
advantage we've seen that the wife is a
much better fighter than her
but however it goes down this is a big
moment i is finally leaving the faceless
men
in king's landing jaime and the tyrells
come to confront the high sparrow
mace tyrell with his magnificent hat
gives an unconvincing speech then the
high sparrow gives a great speech
he presents king tommen who he won over
with the help of margaery
and announces that the crown and the
faith have united as one
as represented by the kingsguard wearing
crowns within stars as their new
symbol which is a bit like stannis fiery
stag the political symbol swallowed by
the religious one
so in one brilliant move the sparrow has
merged his power with the power of the
throne he's taken
all authority away from his opponents by
showing that the king is on his side not
theirs and he's made a great show of
this in front of all the city to win
over the common people
this is masterful political theater this
humble priest has made himself the most
powerful man in the city
and just look at his smile he knows
exactly what he's doing
afterwards tommen removes jaime from the
kingsguard which is a big deal the
kingsguard is meant to be a lifelong
position
jaime is just the second person ever to
be kicked out after barristan
the god has been jaime's life since he
was 15 so he'll really have to
re-examine who he is and what he's doing
with himself
then tommen tells jaime that he's being
sent to the riverlands to help walder
frey
walder frey is the lord of the twins and
the host of the red wedding that killed
rob
and catelyn in season three here we see
him complaining because he lost riverrun
to the tullys and he commands his men to
take the castle back
walder seems mostly motivated by pride
he says he hated serving under the
tullys that everyone's laughing at him
and he refuses to die
until their laughter chokes there are
lots of characters like this in game of
thrones men who so need to feel
important and respected and powerful
that they rant at the people around them
[ __ ] all over their sons and wage whole
[ __ ]
wars the dumb pride of powerful men has
caused terrible damage
in westeros and in the real world we see
blackwalder frey who cut callum's throat
and lame luther frey who stabbed rob's
wife talisa and we can probably expect
these guys to meet a violent end one way
or another
we also see edmure edmure is catlin's
brother in the head of house tully
the red wedding was his wedding and he's
been imprisoned by the phrase ever since
so the phrase want riverrun which is
currently held by brynden blackfish
apparently with the support of the
malistas and the blackwoods and the
brotherhood without banners
riverrun set up for a long siege so
jaime's gonna try and break the siege by
convincing the blackfish to give up the
castle
there's some really cool dialogue in the
books we also know brienne's on her way
to try and recruit the tullys so it'll
be interesting to see how
jaime and brienne interact we also get a
scene between jaime and cersei
at first jaime wants to try to take on
the high sparrow himself but cersei acts
as a voice of reason telling jaime how
much of a bad idea that would be
cersei seems to have become more subdued
this season she's still really angry and
hateful but she's less
obvious about it which honestly probably
only makes her more dangerous
cersei mentions her upcoming trial by
combat and she's confident that her
champion robert strong will succeed
but who will fight against him as the
champion of the faith
well ain't saying he's a gravedigger but
uh
yeah this fight's gonna be huge back
beyond the wall the mysterious figure
who saved bran and meera reveals himself
to be
long lost uncle benjen and he's looking
worse for wear
he says he was stabbed in the gut by a
white walker and left to die but then
the children of the forest stabbed his
heart with a blade of dragonglass which
apparently has turned him into some kind
of a
zombie it's not clear how exactly all
that works but the point seems to be
that he's now become a lot like the book
character coldhands a kind of a friendly
walking corpse
because like coldhands benjen now has
black hands which in coldhand's case
indicates that he's dead
his blood has congealed in his
extremities because his heart has ceased
to beat
also like coldhands this new benjen
seems connected to the three-eyed raven
and the children of the forest he seems
to have been serving them these last few
years
but what exactly was he doing and what
else does he know and
why did he join the watch in the first
place hopefully we'll get answers soon
anyway benjen says bran has now in some
sense become the three-eyed raven he's
like an avatar of the old gods with all
the powers and the knowledge of the
greenseers within him
we still don't quite know what that
means or how it'll work but we do know
that he has
great power and that he'll have to learn
to use it fast if he's to stand against
the walkers
on the way to marine daenerys chats with
daario apparently dany needs a thousand
ships to carry her army to westeros and
well
who do we know who has a thousand ships
dario also says that dany's not a ruler
she's a conqueror
and he's totally right dany isn't much
good at sitting on a throne and being a
politician and making difficult
decisions what she's great at
is sacking cities leading armies riding
dragons burning [ __ ] and as if to
illustrate the point
she flies in on drogon who is [ __ ]
huge now and makes a speech from
dragonback about how she'll take over
westeros with her dothraki behind her
which you know sounds nice in a speech
but we've seen what dothraki conquest
looks like
it's ugly homes are burned and pillaged
people are raped and killed
is this the kind of conquest that
daenerys will lead she's got three big
dragons now will she use them to
burn them all just like her father the
mad king
we'll have to wait and see so a lot
happened this week
benjen's a zombie arya left the faceless
men dany speaks from dragon back the
sparrow makes plays in the capital sam
stands up to his dad the siege of
riverrun is set up and bran binge
watches the last few seasons of thrones
over weirwood net
we've got themes of family with sam and
bran and benjen and even arya connecting
with her past and we see some great
political theater with daenerys and the
high sparrow using symbols of power to
give themselves authority
so while there weren't as many murders
or tits or dicks this episode we've got
some solid exploration of identity
and power thanks for watching and thanks
to all patrons supporting this channel
on patreon including david howe greg
aycock alex kirkendall jake burling
david flores chris amol staz girl oleda
fat dunky brent allen x domas and lucy
liu
cheers
you